Sara!
Awesome!
Let's do it again!
Sara! I have told you many times
to stop doing that.
It's all right. PJ will always catch me.
-You'll get hurt.
-I'll get repaired.
You are human.
When you broke your arm,
it took months for it to get repaired.
-You must not--
-E92, shush! Mute!
Sara!
This needs to be fixed!
Affirmative. I'll give you a cool arm.
Uncle John, got a module?
I want to fix PJ.
What is this place?
-What was that place?
-Enough of that.
-Why?
-It's dangerous.
-How?
-It just is.
I want to go there!
-No!
-Why?
I'm not jumping off anything,
and I'm not going to get hurt.
-So, why is it dangerous? Why?
-Wait!
Expanding language function.
Sharing completed.
Nobody should know
that a human lives here.
Didn't I tell you?
Many of the robots that live outside
believe humans are evil.
If Sara is found,
Sara's life will be in danger.
Affirm you won't put yourself in danger.
-But--
-No, Sara! Affirm!
Sara, watch your mouth!
Not again! I'm the only one
who's not allowed to do anything!
Sara!